This section is on
problem based learning.
Problem based learning is a
constructionist learning strategy, where
the learning process is really motivated
by some central organizing problem.
Now, when we say problem here,
we're not really talking about something
small like a little math problem.
We're talking about something a little
bit bigger and a little bit open ended.
So in ecology, we might have the problem
of figuring out why a certain species
went extinct or in medicine you may have
the problem of given some symptoms and
given some family history,
let's diagnose this patient.
So there are these central motivating
problems behind the learning process.
The power of problem based learning is
that it really teaches students at two
different levels.
On the one hand,
it teaches them the content
knowledge that they need to know.
To diagnose that disease, you would
need to know a list of diseases and
you would need to know which symptoms
correspond to which diseases.
So there's content knowledge at play,
but
problem based learning doesn't
just teach the content knowledge.
It also teaches that content
knowledge in the context of how it
actually would be used
in the real world.
So in the ecology example, it's one
thing to know the biological principles
and the genetics and things like
that that go into that organism.
But its something else to understand
the overall idea of constructing
an explanation of what
happened in that system,
evaluating that explanation against
evidence, and revising it accordingly.
So the power of problem based learning
is it not only teaches students
content knowledge, but it teaches them
content knowledge in the context of how
it would be used out in the real world.
And this is very motivating for
students as well, they get to see that
if I went into a career in this,
this is actually what I would be doing.
This isn't just some material
that's been whitewashed to
use in a classroom environment.
This is actually what people do in
the real world when they work in
these fields.
So it's a great way of
motivating learning and
it's also a great way of teaching.